l'éthique personnelle est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
les dirigeants du g20 approuve la
réforme de la taxation internationale
ils sont réunis à rome ce week end au
coeur des discussions également la lutte
contre le coc vie des contrôles
réchauffement climatique à la veille du
lancement à glasgow de la coop 26
incertitude pour le moment compte à des
engagements forts en faveur du climat
déclaration finale attendue demain
[Musique]
des dizaines de milliers de soudanais
dans la rue pour dénoncer le coup d'état
trois manifestants ont été tués et une
centaine blessés aux morts depuis que
les militaires ont pris le pouvoir lundi
à les protestataires exigent à un
gouvernement civil il n'y aura pas de
négociation avec l'armée et déclare
ministre
la crise diplomatique entre l'arabie
saoudite et le liban criiad rappelle son
ambassadeur à beyrouth soutenu par le
koweït et bahreïn qui décide de faire de
même en soutien à l'allié saoudien la
réaction à des déclarations du ministre
libanais de l'information pas encore
entré au gouvernement il avait qualifié
et d'agression la guerre menée depuis
2015 au yémen par la coalition militaire
conduite par la maison
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
elle prévoit de taxer les
multinationales au minimum à 15% la
réforme de la fiscalité internationale
reçoit donc le feu vert des dirigeants
du g20 à l'issue de la première séance
de travail elle est 20 plus grandes
puissances sont réunis à rome jusqu'à
demain pour évoquer aussi la pandémie la
relance économique mondiale et surtout
le climat alors que la coop 26 démarre
ce dimanche des entretiens bilatéraux
bilatéraux aussi en marge de la séance
plénière compte rendu de cette première
journée des changes avec notre envoyée
spéciale estelle farges
à retenir de cette première session du
g20 sous présidence italienne un dossier
qui semble mettre tout le monde d'accord
il porte sur la fiscalité les chefs
d'état du g20 ont approuvé un accord
qualifié d'historique sur de nouvelles
règles fiscales avec notamment la
possibilité de taxer les multinationales
à minimum au minimum à 15% un feu vert
donc m et le des fiches pour les pays et
bien cela va être de traduire cet accord
dans leur législation si le volet
économique de ce g20 semble s'être
déroulée sans accroc les complications
elle devrait arriver demain avec les
discussions sur le climat malgré les
attentes et les alertes sur ce sujet
majeur rien ne garantit un consensus des
pays en faveur du climat tant leurs
ambitions respectives sont disparates
pourtant à 80% des émissions de co2
proviennent des pays du g20 il va donc
falloir qu'on va convaincre d'autant
plus avant l'ouverture de la coop 26 ce
dimanche les chefs d'état ont aussi à
profiter de leur retour en présentiel
pour organiser tout un tas de rencontres
bilatérales ou en petit comité l'une est
très attendu portait sur le nucléaire
iranien elle a rassemblé boris johnson
angela merkel joe biden et emmanuel
macron les quatre chefs d'état rond dans
un communiqué commun fait part de leurs
vives inquiétudes croissantes sur les
activités nucléaires
de l'iran ils ont appelé téhéran à
changer de cap et à revenir dans le
cadre de l'accord de 2015 sur le
nucléaire iranien un retour au respect
de cet accord pourrait déboucher sur une
levée des sanctions
autre rendez vous est très attendu celui
de boris johnson et d'emmanuel à
maquereau qui se déroulera demain matin
les deux hommes vont aborder l'épineux
dossier de la pêche post briques site
source de tensions entre elles les deux
pays détention et qu'ils sont encore
montée d'un cran aujourd'hui puisque le
premier ministre britannique s'est
plaint auprès d'ursula von der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
de menaces injustifiées de la part de
paris sur le sujet si aucune entente
elle n'est trouvé entre les deux parties
dette britannique pourrait lancer un
recours juridique devant l'union
européenne elle ce rendez vous annuel
des 20 pays les plus riches du monde est
l'occasion de se faire entendre pour les
militants plusieurs manifestations cet
après midi selon la préfecture de police
environ 5000 personnes ont défilé dans
la capitale italienne
des protestataires qui dénoncent
notamment un sommet inadaptée chat une
lutte efficace contre le réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]
en y pensant bien cette coop 26 à
glasgow ça en dit beaucoup sur le fait
que 30 ans de conférence sur le climat
n'a abouti à rien
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont toujours en hausse la crise du
climat continue les injustices sociales
creuse l'écart et un nombre croissant de
gens souffrent attendent à présent 17 25
cette conférence ne sert à rien s'il n'y
a pas de réelle volonté de régler le
problème la coopération internationale
est cruciale mais s'il n'y a pas de
volonté d'agir c'est inutile il n'y a
rien de bon à attendre pour l'instant je
ne vois pas de volonté de résoudre le
problème climatique et de le considérer
comme une urgence on pourrait le
résoudre facilement si on le voulait
mais les politiques ne veulent pas
grand absent du sommet les dirigeants
russes et chinois c'est par
visioconférence qu'ils sont intervenus
ils ont plaidé pour une reconnaissance
mutuelle des vaccins anti corrida
actuellement disponibles les sérums
chinois et russes n'étant notamment pas
homologué par les états unis aient lieu
la correspondance à moscou le verra
gossmann pour la russie les pays du g20
doivent reconnaître mutuellement les
certificats nationaux de vaccination en
appel lancé par vladimir poutine lors de
son intervention en visioconférence au
sommet de rome dans son allocution le
président russe a aussi abordé le
problème de l'inaccessibilité des
vaccins pour plusieurs pays ou encore l
la question de la disponibilité du
vaccin russe août nick v déjà utilisé
dans plus de 70 pays du monde pour les
partenaires de la russie vladimir
poutine a aussi souligné qu'il était
d'accord avec son homologue français
manuel macro quant au rôle accru de
l'organisation mondiale de son tête dans
la gestion de la crise sanitaire écoutez
malgré
les efforts qui ont été faits notamment
pour l'accès aux bains au vaccin
est encore beaucoup de pays qui sont
privés de cet accès je considère qu'une
concurrence déloyale t-il déloyale qui
est mise en place
malhonnête il ya le problème de
reconnaissance des vaccins il ya la
question
qui fait est que qu'il faudrait que l'om
s
accélère la reconnaissance des vaccins
sur leur sécurité leur efficacité leur
fiabilité et plus cela plus vite cela
refait plus vite nous pourrons reprendre
une activité économique normale et
notamment pour le secteur touristique
vladimir poutine n'a pas non plus manqué
d'aborder la crise énergétique en
soulignant que la stabilité des cours
deux bondés de tous les acteurs du
marché écoutez il ya la question de
l'accès aux sources d'énergie et ce que
je voudrais ajouter à ce qui a été dit
c'est que
de la stabilité sur ce marché dépend la
stabilité d'une manière générale de tous
les participants de ce marché de tous
les acteurs il s'agit ici de mettre en
place une politique à long terme avec
des discussions approfondies pragmatique
sur
à partir de considérations purement
économique chers collègues dans
l'ensemble le gage de la reprise de
l'économie à long terme l'augmentation
du niveau de vie de la population
ça veut dire que il faut mettre en place
vis des
conditions de travail hors de toute
discrimination
et c'est là
le l'objectif du travail du g20 je
rappelle que les dirigeants du g20 sont
actuellement réunis à rome pour parler
de la situation sanitaire de la relance
post co vide de l'économie mondiale et
sur la question de la reconnaissance du
vaccin rue spoutnik vais écouter ce
qu'on pense karine bcgo l'ofco
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
il est évident que l'accès de la russie
au marché que ce soit pour le vaccin que
ce soit pour toute autre production
russe est conditionnée également par des
rapports politiques et comme nous le
voyons les agence européenne de
médicaments l'om est-ce à traîne à
chaque fois et roue à chaque fois des
excuses des prétextes pour ne pas
reconnaître le vaccin russe qui est
manifestement idéologiquement
incompatibles alors que finalement au
niveau de résultat des effets sont
quasiment les mêmes que les vaccins
américains qui sont qui sont produits
donc si vous voulez de ce côté là
iliad set 7 jeux ce jeu de la russie
dans la production de vaccins elle
estime qu' il est de son intérêt
national d'avoir sa propre vaccination
et il est souhaitable quand même qu'un
de réduire à sa souveraineté à la
capacité de lure avec son propre parmi
les rencontres bilatérales très attendu
en marge de ce sommet l'entretien feront
très manuelle macro et boris johnson a
les deux hommes doivent échanger demain
sur le sujet de la pêche la france
reproche au royaume-uni d'accorder
troupe top 10 ans préside à ces pêcheurs
elle pourrait tenter un dire dès mardi
aux navires de pêche britannique nous
débarquer dans les ports français le
premier ministre britannique s'en est
donc plein aujourd'hui auprès de la
présidente de la commission européenne
il menace en retour de mettre en oeuvre
des contrôles rigoureux sur les bateaux
européens
boris johnson qui dit préparer
activement une procédure inédite et
coûteux
je pense que les choses qui unissent la
france et le royaume uni sont bien plus
importantes que les choses qui nous
divise et nous allons évidemment
travailler très étroitement avec nos
amis et partenaires pour aller au fond
des problèmes qui nous préoccupent
je dois dire que nous sommes un peu
inquiet que la france soit sur le point
d'en frein dhr ou enfreignent déjà
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
que nous avons conclu
un troisième manifestant a été tué par
balles dans la journée au soudan faux
total depuis le coup d'état militaire de
lundi 12 personnes ont trouvé la mort au
cours de mobilisation
les protestataires demandent le retour
du pouvoir aux civils ils se sont donc à
nouveau rassemblés ce samedi ces mini
google et grégoire xii est
hostile au coup d'état les manifestants
défilent dans les rues de khartoum
un rassemblement à l'appel des partisans
d'un transfert du pouvoir aux civils
dans l'espoir de mettre au fin au régime
militaire
le but de descendre dans la rue
aujourd'hui est de renverser le régime
militaire au sud entre dure depuis plus
de cinquante trois ans nous avons été
témoin de beaucoup de pression de la
part de valve nous espérons que ce jour
soit le dernier jour du régime militaire
au soudan ce vendredi déjà les forces
militaires du général abdel fattah
morales ont tiré des grenades
lacrymogènes sur la foule ils ont aussi
détruit les barricades de fortune des
opposants à ce nouveau pouvoir alors que
les antilles militaires annoncent un
million de participants
ces événements alimente la crainte d'un
samedi sanglant hier les nations unies
ne masquaient pas leur inquiétude
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne le
soudan je veux réaffirmer ma ferme
condamnation du coup d'état il a
nécessité de rétablir le système de
transition qui était en place et demain
une manifestation est annoncée et
j'exhorte les militaires à faire preuve
de retenue et à ne pas faire de nouvelle
victime les gens doivent être autorisés
à manifester pacifiquement
washington a également abondé dans ce
sens
évoquant un vrai test sur les intentions
des militaires la détermination des
protestataires semblent intactes eux qui
organisent leur mobilisation dans tout
le pays malgré les coupures d'internet
ordonnée par les autorités
crise diplomatique entre l'arabie
saoudite et le liban ce sont des propos
tenus cet été par l'actuel ministre de
l'information qui ont mis le feu aux
poudres il n'était alors encore pas
entrer au gouvernement l'émission
télévisée a été diffusée ce lundi le
ministre libanais et qualifie
d'agression la guerre menée depuis 2015
au yémen par la coalition militaire
conduite par ryad il défend les rebelles
houthi pro iranien des propos dont s'est
hâté de se démarquer le chef du
gouvernement libanais affirmant qu'aux
ministres n'exprimer pas la position du
gouvernement
trop tard ryad rappelle son ambassadeur
à beyrouth comme le koweït et bahreïn
décryptage de benoît murat fioles
présidente de l' ong acer
tout discours qui pourrait aller à
l'encontre du discours officiel et est
aussitôt condamné ce qu'il faut quand
même remarquer c'est que georges kordahi
l'alleud qui avait fait cette annonce
alors qu'il n'était pas encore nommé
ministre
en fait ils dénoncent un camp et prend
parti pour l'autre et il souffre il fait
un soutien clair auprès des outils qui
sont aussi responsables de crimes de
guerre
dans la situation de la guerre au yémen
donc on n'est pas sur une situation de
dénonciation des crimes contre
l'humanité qui sont
actuellement dans sont victimes dont est
victime actuellement la population du
yémen mais on est plus sur un un rapport
de force entre
toujours de cette triangulaire entre
l'iran l'arabie saoudite le liban et le
reste de l'actualité internationale en
bref et en images au moins 12 personnes
tuées aujourd'hui au yémen dans une
lauzon près de l'aéroport d'aden la
deuxième ville du pays qui accueille
provisoirement le siège du gouvernement
l'origine de l'explosion n'est pas
connue pour le moment plus tôt dans la
journée un tir d'obus a causé la mort de
trois enfants effet trois autres blessés
à taëz dans le sud ouest du pays selon l
agence de presse officielle assabah qui
accusent les rebelles houthi d'être
responsable de l'attaqué
à les géorgiens appelés aux urnes ce
samedi deuxième tour des élections
municipales dont certaines communes un
scrutin qui se tient dans un pays en
crise ou le principal opposant et ex
président mirel ça sakaachvili ch est
toujours en grève de la faim il proteste
contre sa détention selon lui politique
est le scrutin opposera les candidats du
parti au pouvoir a le rêve géorgien à
ceux du mouvement national uni dont la
figure de proue et l'ancien président
écroué à l'issue du premier tour le
parti au pouvoir était arrivé en tête
dans les petites villes
elle est militaire au pouvoir en
birmanie j'accuse des combattants anti
jantes d'avoir provoqué un incendie dans
une ville de l'ouest du pays vendredi
elle des médias locaux et des témoins
rapportaient que les forces armées de la
jante et est à l'origine du bombardement
de cette même ville après une
confrontation avec des forces locales
d'autodéfense selon des habitants un feu
ravageur a ensuite détruit des dizaines
d'habitations et autres bâtiments en
février l'armée avait été avancé chez le
gouvernement et lui donne scène sushis
mais les mouvements de résistances
persistent dans le pays
engagé chien processus de paix au
proche-orient c'était l'objectif affiché
de la conférence de madrid soutenu par
l'urss et les états unis c'était en 1991
trente ans plus tard qu'en reste-t-il
s'il sera elle a normalisé ses relations
avec plusieurs pays arabes le conflit
israélo palestinien est loin d'être
terminée et la solution à deux états
prônée par beaucoup est difficile à
appliquer la colonisation des
territoires occupés elle se poursuit le
récit de farah mais qui le 30 octobre
1991 à la demande des etats-unis et de
l'union soviétique se tient à madrid la
première tentative de discussions de
paix entre israël et les pays arabes
soit la syrie le liban la jordanie et
les palestiniens sortie victorieuse de
la guerre du golfe la diplomatie
américaine a pour projet de s'affirmer
en tant que médiateur du proche orient
l'objectif de cette conférence entamer
des négociations entre l'état hébreu et
ses voisins
concernant les domaines économique
culturel
sécuritaires et diplomatiques mais
également amorcé des discussions
multilatérales quant à un plan de paix
concernant le conflit israélo
palestinien
si la conférence de madrid n'a pas
abouti à un accord entre la syrie et
israël une solution à deux étapes
concernant les territoires palestiniens
émergent des débats il est alors
question de la mise en place d'une
gouvernance intérimaire palestinienne
une étape qui amènera aux accords d'oslo
en 1993 le 13 septembre 1993
le leader palestinien yasser arafat et
le premier ministre israélien yitzhak
rabin signent des accords de paix à la
maison blanche en présence de bill
clinton suite aux accords d'oslo le
royaume de jordanie signent un traité de
paix avec l'état d'israël
dans le même temps le fatah et le parti
travailliste israélien s'entendre alors
sur des accords sacrifiant les clauses
de non reconnaissance et de destruction
d'israël de la charte de l'ol paie en
plus de reconnaître la souveraineté de
l'autorité palestinienne à gaza et en
cisjordanie
ces accords assurez également la
pérennité des colonies israéliennes
établies au fil du temps par le
gouvernement sur le territoire un
arrangement rejeté par la majorité de
l'opinion publique israélienne et arabes
déçu par l'aboutissement du texte
conséquence le hamas tente de saper les
accords de paix à travers une série
d'attentats suicide et en 1995 itzhak
rabin est assassiné par un terroriste
ultranationalistes israéliens fermement
opposé à l'initiative de paix en 2005
mahmoud abbas qui succède à yasser
arafat à la tête de l'autorité
palestinienne entame des négociations
avec le premier ministre israélien ariel
sharon ces discussions marque la fin de
la deuxième intifada
sans que les négociations de paix entre
les deux parties ne progresse
quatre ans plus tard benyamin nétanyahou
arrive au pouvoir en israël comme en
réponse à la victoire du hamas aux
élections législatives palestiniennes
le premier ministre de droite assume une
politique sioniste fermement opposé aux
accords d'oslo et accélère l'annexion
des territoires palestiniens occupés en
2020 donald trump annoncent la signature
d accords d'abraham un accord de paix
historique qui normalise les relations
entre israël et les emirats-arabes-unis
baleine le soudan et le maroc une
normalisation dénoncée par le fatah qui
voit dans ces accords un abandon complet
de la cause palestinienne
trente ans après la conférence de madrid
les relations entre israël et certains
pays arabes sont apaisées en revanche
les perspectives d'une cohabitation en
paix entre israël et la palestine semble
encore loin d'être accessible comme le
laisse craindre le dernier conflit
israélo-palestinien en mai dernier qui a
coûté la vie à deux cent cinquante six
palestiniens dont 66 enfants
à la reprise épidémique se confirme
selon santé publique france toute
l'europe est concernée si en france la
vaccination a franchi le cap symbolique
des 50 millions de primo vacciner la
situation est plus compliquée ailleurs
notamment en europe de l'est explication
je laisse la miss
l'europe sous la menace d'une nouvelle
vague de kovy de 19 alors que l'épidémie
semble reprendre dans l'hexagone
certains pays d'europe de l'est
connaissent une résurgence des
contaminations comme la bulgarie qui
fait face à une forte hausse des décès
liés au co vide
en terme de surcharge de travail parce
que nous avons déjà une base de
comparaison est que nous vivons cette
situation depuis deux ans maintenant on
peut dire que c'est l'une des périodes
les plus chargées jusqu'à présent comme
l'occupation délier des soins intensifs
est importante ce qui n'est pas bon pour
les patients notre hôpital subi de plein
fouet l'impact de cette pandémie et
comme vous le voyez nous sommes débordés
la bulgarie où une grande partie de la
population refusent la vaccination alors
que le gouvernement vient tout juste
d'instaurer le pass sanitaire des
centaines de bulgares ont manifesté ce
jeudi pour protester contre sa mise en
place
je me demande pourquoi je peux voyage en
métro ou visiter la municipalité locale
et d'autres institutions sans certificat
mais que cela devient obligatoire pour
mon lieu de travail
la raison principale de ma présence ici
et que je suis en total désaccord avec
la discrimination médicale actuelle à
laquelle nous assistons toujours à l'est
l'ukraine qui fait partie des pays les
plus durement touchées par le virus dans
le monde vient de dépasser le seuil de
24 mille nouvelles contaminations par
jour en termes de vaccination c'est le
plus mauvais élève d'europe seulement
18% de la population ukrainienne est
totalement vacciner alors pour tenter
d'améliorer la situation le président a
pris la parole hier et n'a pas hésité à
employer des mots très forts chilien en
ukraine chaque jour nous avons un record
de nouveaux cas et malheureusement un
record de décès
je vous demande fermement d'éteindre les
réseaux sociaux
et d'allumer vos cerveaux
rosso même inquiétude en roumanie qui
observe un rebond épidémique depuis
quelques semaines une situation face à
laquelle des mesures radicales ont été
prises l'instauration d'un couvre feu
mis en place d'un pass sanitaires ou
encore prolongation des vacances
scolaires des restrictions qui font écho
un taux de vaccination encore très
faible dans le pays où seulement un
tiers de la population est entièrement
vacciner et nouveau samedi de
protestation en france contre le pass
sanitaire quelque vingt-cinq mille
manifestants se sont retrouvés un peu
partout dans l'hexagone notamment à lyon
vous le voyez sur ces images une
mobilisation en baisse par rapport à la
semaine dernière fait ministère de
l'intérieur a recensé 168 actions sur
tout le territoire avec
3320 manifestants à paris faut quatre
cortèges avait été déclarée à la
préfecture le président des patriotes
florian philippot dénonce lui
l'hypocrisie de l'état face à la
situation sanitaire dans les hôpitaux
les routes
et nos quêtes et vit que du conseil
scientifique donc c'est quand même des
gens proches de maquereau qui disent que
carly sur cinq à l'hôpital et faire mes
potes le soignant et b ont dit non non
je suis pas certain de ce chiffre aux
jambes ou ya comme ça donc on va faire
une enquête sur l'anc est dans la
réalité c'est qu'effectivement les de
l'hôpital est dans un état pitoyable
c'est cent mille lits fermés depuis 1993
donnant de l'union européenne chaque
année et ceux qui font semblant de
découvrir aujourd'hui sont des
hypocrites nous le disons chaque année
il y en à peine fait permet d'éviter les
gouvernements français au pays ce
maquereau avec l'an dernier on a permet
5700 lille chiffres officiels de la
drees ministère de la santé plus que
depuis 2013 au roi 16e samedi de
contestation qui dépasse la dénonciation
du pass sanitaire hausse du carburant
baisse du pouvoir d'achat les
revendications se multiplient le regard
de christophe tel maire centriste de
janvry et gérard filoche porte parole de
la gauche démocratique et sociale
que ya un mal être que vous vivez une
situation qui met beaucoup de gens mal à
l'aise on peut parfaitement le
comprendre que des gens s'en empare
idéologiquement pour essayer
d'entretenir du venin ça existe aussi
mais on peut parfaitement comprendre que
les gens soient pas heureux mais qui
peut être heureux dans une situation
comment on la vit aujourd'hui rapport à
la situation d'une grande partie des
campagnes de la province où nos
habitants besoin de prendre leur voiture
pour aller bosser et que c'est vrai que
niveau du 7e arrondissement de paris
l'ont pas encore compris
cette réalité du terrain et c'est demain
le soulèvement les mobilisations les
doutes les craintes les méfiances des
gens viennent de ddd mille manoeuvre du
gouvernement matt ronde ses discours
successifs et en vérité la question peut
être tranchée que politiquement pour
rétablir la confiance faut se
débarrasser du gouvernement actuel qui a
tellement fait mal depuis deux ans
depuis le début on n'a pas eu de mal
passer elle pas de lit pas de gagnant
pas de curare pas de médicaments pas de
blouse pas de seringue on n'a rien eux
tout a été fait en retard et donc c'est
de là que se provoque la situation
actuelle on est un peu entre deux
situations quoi les gens essaient de
rattraper le temps perdu elle tend
retrouver ça sera quand il y aura un
million de personnes dans la rue je
souhaite de tout mon coeur contre ce
gouvernement
et concernant le pass sanitaire sein du
raid usage fait débat au parlement le
projet de loi de vigilance sanitaire est
actuellement à l'étude il prévoit de
prolonger la mesure jusqu'à l'été les
sénateurs plaident eux pour le mois de
février ils tenteront de s'accorder avec
les députés mais c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui aura le dernier mot
[Musique]
vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous
est ce la fin de cette édition se
retrouve à 21h pour un nouveau journal à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique pendant la
rendant encore plus cooney sq justement
c'est une nouvelle forme de
communication assez verticale utiliser
des influenceurs pour un sac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages
on a l'impression qu'on descende des
chimpanzés et pas du tout les chimpanzés
nous sommes cousins germains maternelle
qui était bretonne me disais si toi tu
es descendu sa joie sur rampe a révélé
nous un secret vous en avez mangé du
mammouth je me trouve à fouiller en
sibérie et puis un beau matin dans le
trou que j'avais commencé à creuser je
trouve que les tubes comme c'est quelque
chose de billard et des grands filaments
je suis étonné je râle je dirais que ce
sont des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes à saint pétersbourg dans
l'une des villes les plus renommés de la
russie moderne située au bord de la neva
son architecture somptueuse et ses
canaux qui la traversent la rentrée
célèbre pour sa beauté on l'appelle la
capitale du nord mais elle est surtout
nommé la venise du nord
[Musique]
saint pétersbourg est fondée en 1703 par
le premier rang peur russe pierre le
grand sur des terres froides et déserte
conquise sur les suédois lors de la
guerre du nord
l'empereur n'a pas lésiné sur l'argent
les hommes et les moyens pour édifier la
nouvelle capitale joyau de la russie
fenêtre sur l'europe grâce à son port
saint pétersbourg a joué pendant deux
siècles un rôle clé dans la vie
politique culturelle et sociale de l'
empire russe jusqu'à sa chute
[Musique]
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale la
ville a cruellement souffert a siégé
pendant presque 900 jours elle a connu
une terrible famine et des températures
glaciales c'est l'une des pages les plus
tragiques de l'histoire de la russie
moderne
[Musique]